what is a Spearman correlation
spearman's rank correlation examines the
relationship between two variables the
Spearman rank correlation is the
non-parametric counterpart of the
Pearson correlation Spearman correlation
does not use the raw data but the ranks
of the data let's look at this with an
example we measure the reaction time of
8 computer players and ask their age the
reaction time is already sorted by size
we are now doing the same with age here
we have the smallest value there the
second smallest value and so on and so
forth let's take a look at this in a
scatter plot here we see the raw data of
age and reaction time but now we would
like to use the rankings so we form
ranks from the variables age and
reaction time to calculate beam and
correlation now we simply calculate the
P using correlation from the ranks so
the Spearman correlation is equal to the
Pearson correlation only that the ranks
are used instead of the raw values